[Music]
channing tatum is back on the grind
[Applause]
no we're not talking about that
that was supposed to be cold in the yeti
village
the 40 year old actor posted a photo on
instagram
wearing nothing but sweatpants showing
off his rock solid abs and ripped arms
i need to have a modeling agency or
something channing wrote
daddy is finally back oh yes he is
it's kind of like a whole the whole
package and we're going to see him back
on the big screen
channing is currently working on a new
movie titled dog which he's co-directing
and starring in
but the actor says it hasn't been easy
for him
it's been a crazy ride following his
divorce from jenna dewan in 2018
and his on and off relationship with
jessie j
channing says it's been a long road back
injuries life [ __ ] and just insanity in
general
but he's hopeful for the future writing
gonna be a fun
next 10 year run to all those that have
been there for me and held me down
through it all
i love you i'm gonna make you proud
let's go
channing ended his post by pointing out
the bottle of hand sanitizer
reminding everyone to keep it clean out
there
hey you're welcome uh we're pretty sure
no one was paying attention to that pure
rail bottle
oh man at least you said